[Music]
far away as north as we can go once
stood an enchanted forest you see an
enchanted forest yes it was a magical
place but something went wrong since
then no one can get in what would I do
without you you'll always have me
[Music]
how that seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa there's this voice voice what
does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you Anna no excuse me I climb
to the North Mountain survived a frozen
heart and saved you from my ex-boyfriend
so you know I'm coming that's normal
where are we how did you get in the
forest and this parted forest impossible
where did you learn magic
[Music]
you can't just follow me in the fire
and don't run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
I believe in you Elsa
or anything
quick question if the whole putting up
some mortal games are gonna be a regular
thing
I'm a demon on Stratis mistake of your
life we didn't even kiss you
[Music]
we all got it okay all off you're up
okay so much easier now that I can read
lightning round
boys against girls I'm ready I'm ready
go unicorn I scream castle okay
teapot Mouse oh I don't think Olaf
should get to rearrange enjoying your
new permafrost Olaf
I'm just living the dream ona oh how I
wish this could last forever hmm
and yet change mocks us with their
beauty what's that
forgive me maturity is making me poetic
tell me you're older end us all knowing
do you ever worry about the notion then
nothing is permanent
no you I can't wait until I'm aged like
you so I don't have to worry about
important things
Kristoff can I borrow your wagon and
spend mhm I'm not very comfortable with
the idea of that you are not going alone
oh no no I have my powers to protect me
you don't excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend and I did
it all without powers so you know I'm
coming me too
I'll Drive I'll bring this max I will
look after your people please make sure
they stay out of the kingdom until we
return of course let's let them know
honor
I'm worried for her we have always
feared Elsa's powers were too much for
this world now
we must pray they are enough I won't let
anything happen to her okay all your up
unicorn oh oh I should get to rearrange
doesn't matter this is gonna be a cinch
oh distracted worried how's Elsa seemed
weird to you she seems like Elsa
there's voice voice what does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers
across the enchanted lands and into the
unknown we do this together okay
the spirits will challenge you every
step of the way
[Music]
that's normal
who are you I'm hola
oh sorry yeah I just find clothes
restricting
Oh
should I know what that means
try to screen
magic disappearing without you see bein
lose herself to it believe in you more
than anyone or anything
if anyone can save arendelle it's you
you guys cope with the ever increasing
complexity of thought that comes with
maturity
don't you that you don't know what I
stepped it to say that this movie is
ambitious is big understatement we're
going outside of arendelle or the world
is expensive frozen to is a much bigger
world
it begins with Elsa hearing this voice
and we go on this quest to discover why
she's hearing it you've been hearing a
voice and you didn't think to tell me on
that journey they uncover some deep
secrets about their past and she knows
she needs to find those answers this
movie has grown with its audience these
characters have developed like they have
and they're experiencing new things Olaf
has become a learning snowman the water
that makes up you and me has passed
through at least four animals before us
[Music]
and after getting older and maturing I
think they really rehab the best and one
another promise me we do this together
okay I promise
frozen to introduces new characters that
I think are going to become as iconic as
Anna Elsa Kristoff Sven and Olaf
sterling K Brown plays the tenant with
tears
you got he's a soldier he's a protector
he's fiercely loyal to arendelle just
when you think you found your way life
will throw you on to a new path
ayuh play Queen and Doudna Anna and
Elsa's mother having had such a warped
working with her has been amazing smooch
in the overall takeaway is this
beautiful notion that you can learn from
the past and make the future better
that's it you'll feel the story growing
you feel the stakes getting bigger I
can't lose to us but I think you're
really in for an epic adventure
this is it everyone ready the past is
not what it seems
you must go north find the truth I'm
going with the honor no excuse me I
climb to the North Mountain survived a
frozen heart and saved you from my
ex-boyfriend so promise me we do this
together okay I promise
need to find the answers about the past
I believe you Elsa
more than anyone or anything
frozen - it's a hole putting on some
mortal danger gonna be a regular thing
pretty peachy tickets available now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]